did you pick up the Modern Warfare Vault
Edition good news you're getting 10
hours of Double XP and double weapons XP
tokens initially this offer was only
available to purchases of the Vault
Edition that picked up the game via one
of the previous recent Call of Duty
titles Modern Warfare 2019 Black Ops
cold war or Vanguard however since
almost no one purchases a game in that
manner the vast majority of people that
picked up the Vault Edition were not
eligible for these bonuses leading to
confusion amongst many of the players
that picked up the more expensive
version of the game quote we understand
there has been some confusion about an
in-game store exclusive reward for the
vault Edition reads an image tweeted out
by the official Call of Duty Twitter
therefore we've decided to reward all
players that currently own or purchase
any version of the Modern Warfare 2
vault Edition with 10 hours of Double XP
tokens and 10 hours of double weapon XP
tokens current owners who have not
already received the tokens should
expect to see them in their account over
the next 48 hours that means even if you
purchase the Vault Edition after this
announcement was made via the means of
your choice you're still going to net
yourself those Double XP and double
weapons XP tokens which yeah you should
get if you're paying a hundred dollars
for this game now if only there was
Double XP in Marvel snap the new hit
Mobile card game from former Hearthstone
devs and my personal latest Obsession if
you've been playing Marvel snap and
you've wanted to absolutely wipe the
floor with your friends that are also
just as addicted you won't have to wait
long an update that is coming to the
game before the end of the year will
allow you to do just that as reported by
The Washington Post a new battle mode
will be coming to Marvel snap before the
end of 2022 and will allow players to
challenge challenge specific people like
friends as opposed to using the game's
current matchmaking system but matches
will work differently to the regular
mode already in the game in the current
mode players play for ranked points with
the snap mechanic effectively serving as
a way to double down on the amount of
ranked points on the line as it wouldn't
exactly be fair to bet ranked points on
matches between friends battle mode will
instead introduce an HP system each
player will have 10 HP with the number
of points on the line for a given match
instead affecting the losing players HP
pool as opposed to rank battle mode
matches will consist of multiple rounds
and the first player to lose all their
HP will lose the match Marvel snap is
currently the fifth most popular
free-to-play game on the App Store but
can also be played via steam if you
haven't checked it out yet I implore you
do unless you have responsibilities in
your life you absolutely cannot neglect
get as much Marvel snapping out of the
way while you can because the next major
installment in the Final Fantasy
franchise Final Fantasy 16 is almost
complete quote about 95 States game
director Hiroshi takai when asked by
Japanese Gaming magazine famitsu how
much of the game was done in a more
thorough follow-up to the question takai
added that the development team was
playing through the game and addressing
any issues along the way game producer
naoki Yoshida added that he expected a
release date for the game to be
announced by the end of the year hey
that's the deadline for Marvel snaps new
game mode too awesome how are you
enjoying Modern Warfare 2 so far are you
as addicted to Marvel snap as I am let
us know in the comments below and we'll
see you next week for more Gamespot news